it's very hard to be in relationship
with other men and have real substantial
relationships about your life about the
challenges that you're facing the amount
of men who casually throw their problems
out into the friend group at the bar and
talk about it in such a nonchalant way
and to be met with crickets did any of
those guys get any solutions did any of
those guys get any support they're using
the humor and the Casual nature of the
way that they're putting it across
largely to not actually have to accept
the fact that it could be a big Problem
by doing that it allows you to deal with
the surface level joke that everybody
can laugh at whilst not actually dealing
with this Iceberg that's kind of lurking
underneath I think for the majority of
men that is the state of their male
friendships it's like a mile wide and an
inch deep and I think what many men are
craving are more depth oriented
relationships prioritizing those types
of relationships I think for a lot of
men is one of the most substantial
things that they can do